and that's why i think omicron is the
great equalizer everybody's been
vaccinated everybody hasn't been
vaccinated most of them are just going
to get infected it's going to take away
the stigma of covid it's going to
generate a lot of immunity and it's
going to push us towards a phase where
this is more like a cold
i've argued that we're already in the
phase where every single societal
mandate and restriction should be
removed there should be no vaccine
passports there should be no mandates
there should be no mask mandates every
single individual can make a decision
now
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a doctor youtuber and
entertainer dr dr zubin damania welcome
to trigonometry
hey guys nice to see you this is a lot
of fun uh it's so good to have you on
the show uh before we get into the
conversation uh let's just get the first
question out of the way who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life that land you here
talking to us on youtube
these are this is like the hardest
now i'm really like intimidated by these
questions they're actually hard so so my
story is i'm uh um
i'm a
second gen first generation indian
american uh parents came from india both
of them were physicians so i had no
choice like i was going into medicine it
was like you know being a being named
jeeves or something like you're going to
be a butler there's no choice in life so
i ended up drifting into medicine went
to ucsf uh in san francisco for my
medical training and then stanford for
my residency training in internal
medicine and then i practiced at
stanford for about a decade as a
hospital-based physician so an internist
who just takes care of hospitalized
patients
was deputy chief of medicine did some
stupid stuff like that to pad the resume
and then left went to las vegas because
i got very burned out uh it was really
what we call moral injury it was you
know having to work in a system that's
so fundamentally
opposed to what we actually are as
caring human beings that it really
weighs on you and over time i decided i
just can't do this anymore so i left
went to
las vegas started a clinic there called
turntable health which was a primary
care collaborative uh health clinic that
that functioned on a model i call health
3.0 which is more integrative
and you're actually paid to do the right
thing for patients instead of just do
stuff to patients ran that for about
three years we were a little early so
our partners actually took that model
and made it national and now are growing
nationally but i then decided to focus
on what i do
reasonably well which is educate and
communicate and try to entertain and
that's the z-dog md character and
channel on youtube and facebook and all
the other jazz so that's been
where i am now is the z dog md show i'm
an adjunct clinical professor at uh
university of nevada las vegas and
that's how i'm sitting right here well
it's so great to have you on and let's
get straight into it because the reason
we wanted to have you on it and you talk
about this a lot in your videos not just
the medical side but i think also what
big tech and social media have done to
our brains and the the way i re you
describe it i really like because you
talk about the pull into the two echo
chambers and we saw it here with brexit
then we saw it with trump but now with
covet it's just got so much more
pronounced i would readily confess to
being pulled into those echo chambers
both of them at different points at
different times during the pandemic
but what i really like about you is i
think you do have a heterodox
approach you don't buy into some of the
mainstream bs that we're being told but
you're also not going off the deep end
another direction which is i think a
great perspective to explore so can you
give us your heterodox bona fides to
start with like do cloth masks work our
max vaccine mandates wrong like all that
good stuff oh vaccinated or unvaccinated
people unclean yes
filthy
consider see look look i'm i'm a
relapsed uh or should i say reformed
liberal myself so i consider humans good
on paper but in reality gross so just
across the board right so yeah this was
this was sort of my take on the thing as
kovitz started spinning up
it became clear to me that we've lost
our damn minds very early on like the
amount of
you you could feel it there was a kind
of a hive collective mind that had
established early on that was fear-based
panic-based and it was affecting
everybody in this very interesting way
and and so my earliest stuff actually
was to
sit there and go guys i i don't really
know that
a cloth diaper on your face is going to
do [ __ ] for an airborne virus now i got
a lot of things wrong because i was
thinking you know it probably was
surface transmission like say norovirus
or other things like that and i was
talking to experts who felt that was the
case but then the other thing i said was
boy it seems really crazy to lock down
schools when kids are the one class of
human here that seems relatively
minimally affected by this and that's
going to cause the poor
the most because this is a regressive
tax on the poor so everybody here who's
screaming about this you really ought to
think about that the other thing i was
very concerned about actually early on
was i didn't think a vaccine was doable
because looking at the history of
vaccines we'd never done anything like
this i was quite skeptical and i
actually interviewed paul offit who is
the big vaccine guy and we were jointly
skeptical we were also concerned that
the whole process had already become
politicized and were worried that a
rushed vaccine would actually set back
vaccine
uptake with kids vaccines forever so we
were talking about this stuff kind of
early on
uh
and
the idea that you can lock down the
economy and somehow control this without
ultimately paying a price was crazy so i
was sort of yelling about substance
abuse mental health all the other area
under the curve damage that
these the response to coronavirus was
doing so that and i got a lot of [ __ ]
from my tribe of healthcare
professionals who were like aren't you
seeing these people in the icu and all
of that i'm like i am i'm also seeing
all the other damage that we're doing
that that you're so busy right now
understandably overwhelmed in the
hospital that you don't see it well now
even healthcare workers see it right
because their own kids are affected and
their own mind state is affected and so
we actually grew our audience quite a
bit talking in what i call an alt-middle
way like let's just try to see where the
truth is between all the hive minds
that's very hard to do because we're all
captured ourselves you know like i fall
into my own patterns myself it's v you
have to be vigilant constantly
it's such a good point you always have
to be vigilant constantly because
we naturally have a bias
and and the thing that i found really
really
worrying with this entire pandemic is a
really religiousity of people
you know that you know that they firmly
believe in campaign and i'll i'll give
you an example so because of uh
trigonometry i'm on a variety of
facebook forums where i post our clips
both right and left and i'm on this
forum on facebook called left wing and
proud where you belong yeah exactly
right
so you can imagine the type of people
were there and i saw this post by this
one woman and it actually got to me a
little bit i felt quite upset for her
she went
i've worn a mask at all times i'm triple
vaxxed i'm sure i'm isolating um i try
and stay away from people i have covid
what did i do wrong
and i and i just thought you haven't
done anything wrong you've contracted an
airborne virus
you know what you just pointed your
heart like opens for these folks because
what it is is and this is okay so what's
interesting is the religiosity this idea
that we've somehow
filled
a hole left by the absence of god in the
world now with this new religion in two
different bubbles right what peter
lindbergh calls the thesis bubble and
the antithesis bubble and each of them
is a collective hive mind that's kind of
instantiated that's made by a bunch of
individual neurons that kind of look
like us holding these going like dislike
share comment right so this woman
clearly was in the
in the thesis bubble was doing
everything stay home wear the mask put
the twitter
name that says i'm bobby wear the mask
mcgee and a picture of like them with
like a respirator and a darth vader mask
and all of this
and they're in that tribe they're
signaling they're in that tribe and then
what happens is if you actually get
covid it's this massive amount of shame
because the feedback from that
collective brain down to that neuron is
you done [ __ ] up aaron like
this is not okay
and they feel it and then it's it's a
kind of defeat now what's interesting is
on the uh in the other bubble antithesis
it's the same thing
just now the uncleanness is not getting
covered the uncleanness is getting
vaccinated having these mrna particles
lipid nanoparticles building up in your
ovaries causing you know infertility
causing
myocarditis and all the stuff that is
rampant in that particular hive mind so
both have a religious sort of fervor and
actually the antithesis crowd adds a
revelations kind of component to it like
if we can just isolate and show that
these people are part of a conspiracy
that are doing this for money and power
and control we can end this pandemic
because we can just give people the
sacred sacraments of ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine and so on whereas the
thesis tribe is like no no no everyone
must have the baptism the baptism of
vaccine and if you don't get baptized
with the vaccine you are an impuri
impuritor and must be excommunicated
from the tribe and
harshly punished with the scarlet letter
of you unvaccinated right and i love the
way you explain that one of the other
things you do very well i think is you
try to declare your biases so in this
conversation before we get into the
medical stuff i kind of want to
francis maybe can do this for himself
but for me
i definitely definitely definitely
definitely instinctively lean to the
antithesis tribe there's no question
about that right i am skeptical about
many of the public health measures that
have been taken uh i think the bs we got
about masks don't wear a mask then wear
a mask and they work then they don't
like all of that complete nonsense i'm
skeptical about whether lockdowns
did have a positive net impact over a
10-year period we won't know that for a
while and i'm hesitant to say oh
definitely helped etc etc etc i do think
and i'm willing to to be persuaded
otherwise but i do suspect we're not
quite being told the full truth about
the vaccine maybe because we don't know
the full truth about the vaccine but all
of that so a lot of my questions are
going to be from someone who who is
prone to the antithesis tribe but is
willing to hear a rational argument as
well right so so yeah go for it no no i
was just gonna say that's great when you
put when you put where your bias is
coming from and also
what would
are you convinceable are you rational in
other words if i were to give you data
one way or the other would you change
your mind and if if people say up front
no there's nothing you can say that's
ever going to change my mind this is
what i believe then you know the
conversation can be kind of limited you
don't need to waste a lot of time right
right so with with that in mind zubin so
let's get into the medical stuff right
because there's a lot to talk about and
you've you've charted a few other things
already so one of the things the
antithesis tribe feels very strongly
about
and it's been amplified by people like
peter mccullough and robert malone and
others
is that
early treatment
is not getting enough
attention that there are drugs that
could help people that are not being
prescribed and we've seen for example
with monoclonal antibodies for which i
believe you yourself say there's good
evidence that they work in the uk they
only got approved like a week or two ago
and only for the most like desperately
vulnerable people right now that could
be just because they're more expensive
than vaccines or whatever but they work
right and and the antithesis tribe says
well look you can you know you don't
need to get a vaccine that maybe is a
little bit suspect you could just get
this right ivor mechtin people have
questions about hydroxychloroquine what
is the truth about all that stuff
boy you know these are great questions
because the truth is there's a lot we
don't know in general but i can kind of
fill in some of the blanks and i'll tell
you where my biases are up front i'm
actually with you in the antithesis bias
against the policy measures that have
been implemented whether it's mandates
lockdowns school closures
how we dispense information how we
educate the public how we talk to them
i'm firmly you're against leadership
what's that you're against censorship
against censorship entirely like you
should never de-platform folks ever ever
first of all it won't even accomplish
what you're trying to do it will
backfire on you as it has been shown
time and time again mccullough malone
etc the mainstream it's backfires on
them because rogan will then give them a
platform that's bigger than anything the
mainstream could have done
and so
my bias is a more libertarian bias on
that side but then i have all my medical
training and and this is what creates a
it's a bias but it's also a way of
looking at the world so for example i
remember i saw your great uh podcast on
how you guys came down with covid and
you were talking through like what it
was like i think for francis he was
coughing up blood and had to go in and
and be seen and this is what the gp told
him in the er after waiting outside in
the cold and all this i mean it's a
really harrowing tale very common but
one thing that that struck me that was
interesting this is where the medical
training actually comes in handy i think
um
constantine you had said you know i
don't know why you would cough up blood
if you're if they're worried about blood
and i got that completely wrong
so now you you got it wrong it's true
but why right so not out of any like
stupidity lack of intelligence any of
that
and it's also that right
i'll cop to that too but it's because
you didn't go through four years of
medical school and three years of
residency in 10 years of stuff so when i
saw that i'm like oh yeah because
the the chances of actually killing lung
tissue around a blood clot which then
causes a pulmonary infarction which and
then cause hemoptysis which is the
medical term for blood coming up is a
five to seven percent risk of severe
blood clot and so yes that's why you
think of it but how would you have the
tools to know that de novo you couldn't
unless you asked an expert or did a lot
of research so this is where my bias
comes in is i actually know how to look
at data and we've been burned in
medicine many many times by data that
seems kind of promising and it turns out
to be horseshit when you really study it
with a good randomized controlled trial
so that is the basis of this
the question now becomes early therapies
right early therapeutics boy that has a
strong emotional resonance because
people are like well if you could just
treat this thing early like we do with
strep throat or bacterial infections or
even hiv if you're early in an hiv
course you treat with antivirals it's a
cocktail it's complicated you can
actually live a long long time it
becomes a chronic disease like the magic
johnson effect right but
with
viruses in general
the pre-test
likelihood that that's going to work
that we have good therapeutics is very
low even repurposed drugs just because
we just don't have great therapeutics
for viruses so already there's kind of a
concern that is it gonna are we gonna
have something that works so in the
early days i think and i think this is
where the antithesis crowd the leaders
in that network of antithesis so the
mcculloughs and the malones they really
um
have a little bit of there's a bit of a
misleading angle here that nobody's
talking about therapeutics i can tell
you we were there in the early pandemic
and that's all we were talking about
because nobody really trusted that we
were going to get to a vaccine and even
when it looked like a vaccine might come
nobody trusted that it would actually
have any good efficacy so there were
forms and forms and forms of
international doctors i had people on my
show talking about what are the things
that might work and we talked about
hydroxychloric when we talked about pros
and cons we talked ivermectin when it
became a bigger thing we started talking
about that and everybody was open to
these things working the thing is we've
been burned a million times and a lot of
observational trials a lot of
correlation
doesn't pan out when you actually
measure it in a gold standard randomized
controlled trial and that's what
happened with hydroxychloroquine and
ivermectin the data that has come out
that's really good quality data is still
like well i'm not seeing it yet now that
could change right you could see
something change but the idea that these
therapies were withheld now monoclonals
are an interesting one
they absolutely help absolutely and in
the u.s they've been recommended by nih
from very early on so it's really a
question of what's the uptake they're
difficult to administer because you have
to often do infusions or subcutaneous
injections they can be expensive but in
the u.s we don't care about that we'll
throw anything at people right because
insurance will reimburse it which means
ultimately we're all paying for it
whereas in the uk nhs does look at oh
what's the net public health benefit for
the cost and so on right so
in the us monoclonals have been
available now are they easy to get no
should they be easier to get absolutely
so that's a policy thing but it's not a
science thing the science we've been
talking about it and i think even at at
the highest level so that it's not that
monoclonals have been suppressed in
favor of vaccine
um so that's the kind of therapeutic now
here's another thing something like
fluvoxamine which is an antidepressant
right
the
trials of good randomized control trials
showed a good reduction in
hospitalization rate and possibly
mortality
using this very safe antidepressant that
has probably some anti-inflammatory
effects that's why it seems to work and
i've been in cahoots talking to the lead
investigators and all that
and people just don't seem to talk about
it even though it's there so that is a
valid concern of of people like malone
and mccullough like why aren't we
jumping up and down talking about this
i've had people on my show like dr marty
mccary who has there are lots of
heterodox
doctors heterodox who that was stupid
who are
talking about this stuff but they're but
but when you listen to pure antithesis
they'll say nobody's talking about this
except for these really prominent
physicians like marty mccary vinai
prasad um jay bhattacharya these are
people that are very pro-vaccine say for
example but also pro-therapeutics pro
science pro all of this other stuff and
they're quite antithesis in many ways in
terms of policy
so yeah
so zubin isn't the problem again going
back to censorship well the moment you
start taking down the mcculloughs and
the malones you instantly give them a
gravitas because people like oh you know
they're talking truth to power and fisa
can't handle it because they know the
truth about the vaccine and then
everybody like you said flocks but then
what that means is is that we lose faith
in the mainstream we lose faith in the
vaccines
the mainstream has deserved the loss of
faith that it's gotten with trying to
silence people that's insane trying to
stigmatize conversations like you know
this thing where uh fauci and and
nih director francis collins in the
united states were trying to discredit
dr j bhattacharya who's been on my show
twice he's the most reasonable rational
caring passionate guy he has a
difference in opinion on how the policy
should work in this and he was one of
the earliest people to say hey the
infection fatality rate in other words
if everybody who's infected whether you
measure them or not
of this disease is actually more like
0.2 to 0.3 percent that's not super high
so why are we shutting down all of our
way of life and disrupting our social
fabric and ruining the economy and
causing wealth disparity that's going to
ruin lives including health why are we
doing that for this well mainstream
totally screwed that up and they deserve
all the hate for that right but what's
ended up happening is and this i think
this started early on because you had
trump as president who was endorsing a
therapeutic uh hydroxychloroquine and i
think that started then to spiral the
tribalization because if you do look at
antithesis it does lean right
libertarian more
and i think that started a kind of thing
and then the left really rolled with
that then they wouldn't even listen
about therapeutics right because it was
like no no no we already went through
this hydroxychloroquine thing it's like
okay stop stop you're supposed to
actually pay attention to science here
there's no thus science that's dogma
this is a process
so i'm with you by stopping like you
know and rogan will even say hey you got
canceled on twitter come on my show and
i'll give you a a place a very friendly
place right because rogan
does skew a little antithesis although
he's a synthesis guy he really is if you
listen to rogan talking you're like this
guy's trying to find truth yeah
absolutely and this is why i've said i'm
not sure that peter mccullough or robert
malone are necessarily right about what
they say but i i massively respect joe
for having them on because someone has
to push back against a [ __ ] durbin we
can't let the big tech just shut
everything down and censor because
they're only going to make things worse
so i respect joe moore for having these
people on even if they're wrong about
every single thing that they say
personally that's my own view
hey francis are you worried about big
tech stealing your data i've forgotten
how to switch my phone on why doesn't it
have an on button like my walkman
never mind those of you whose technology
extends beyond the 1980s are rightly
concerned about your data being stolen
and sold on to third parties a lot of
this data is being harvested from apps
on your phone one of our fans has
designed an app called synthetic notes
and it is like a normal note-taking app
with several major differences that's
right unlike most apps it does not use a
subscription model once you've paid for
it that's it unlike most apps that will
charge you a hundred dollars a year i
knew that appeal to you synthetic notes
also stores all your data on your local
machine
away from cloud databases this combined
with the fact that it is not a
subscription app means that synthetic
notes never needs to connect to the
internet you can safely quarantine the
app and it will still work completely
fine by paying for synthetic notes
you're buying back your privacy and as
someone who's tracked day and night by
uncle vlad this really is peace of mind
and it still does all the things you'd
expect from a note-taking app so you'll
be able to write a to-do list take down
notes for work or even write that
rubbish first novel we all have in our
heads that no one wants to read that's
no way to talk about my book go to
syntheticapps.com and use our code
trigonometry to get 25 off that's right
go to syntheticapps.com
and use our code trigonometry to get 25
off
but let's come back to to the medicine
so
we've covered early therapeutics
the other concern that people have is
the side effects of the vaccine and that
would be myocarditis that would be
menstrual changes in women
we see particularly with healthy young
athletes and this is a i don't know
whether it's a real trend or it's an
observed trend or whatever but we see
particularly with footballers
the number of footballers that used to
have a seizure on the pitch or during
training used that we would know of that
we would know of right there would be it
would be happening in in the third
league in slovenia but but but we
wouldn't know about it right
used to be like one or two a year and
this year there's been a dozen right now
that could be because it's being covered
differently but people talk about that
as being an issue so
the anticipated tribe suspects that the
vaccines are not as safe as we're being
told what is the truth in your opinion
about that
yeah this is and this is one where
i had to look at my own bias very
carefully because going into covid i was
as pro-vaccine like i would i look like
the guy from hellraiser just a bunch of
needles in my face like walking around
like that's how pro-vaccine i was
because
the vaccines that we had are really
really really good for childhood
diseases for preventing cancer through
hpv vaccine for preventing shingles and
shingrix and pneumonia with pneumovax
and flu
meth but at least it's something so i
was very pro those vaccines they're
quite safe but not without rare
complications that can happen right so
that being said
going into coronavirus there's that
skepticism and part of the skepticism
was we've never done this before this is
new technology with mrna even though the
technology is a decade plus old and to
listen to robert malone it's actually
from 1988 right when he published his
paper on wrapping mrna in a lipid uh
glob that allows it to get taken up by
mouse cells and um
so but still sorry to interrupt this
mrna vaccine
am i right to say it's it's obviously
going to be the first one rolled out at
this scale right we've never seen
anything remarkably on this other level
so it is new in that way right this is
right and i'll be honest with you when i
sat down i was there uh like in january
as a healthcare guy getting my shot
i
damn near had a panic attack when they
gave it to me because i it was again the
human instinct is and look i'm
very trained in this stuff and i looked
at the data i talked to experts who've
been working on the trials i was
comfortable with the safety of it but
there was still an unconscious response
where i was like i'm going to die now or
something terrible is going to happen so
it is normal human behavior to question
putting
new [ __ ] in your body um and we should
actually encourage that and actually
talk about that instead of saying oh
you're an anti-vaxxer by bringing this
up right so the mrna stuff is is a new
way to do something that's quite old
which is use your body's immune system
and teach it how to respond to a
a virus and this is another reason i
have a bias towards
vaccines as opposed to therapeutics you
need all of them you need all of them
but this is why i think a lot of
physicians have a bias towards vaccines
because if you can prevent something
it's way better than having to get it
because you still have the complications
of getting it potentially things like
long covet et cetera but the other
reason is
therapeutics are trying to hack the body
it's they're trying to bypass something
the body does in some way to try to do
it better or differently and that's why
they have all these kind of side effects
because the body is actually pretty
complicated
with vaccines what you're doing is
taking a very small dose of something
much lower dose than you would give in
therapeutics and you're teaching you're
actually taking what the body already
does which is its complex immune system
and you're training it to do something
it would normally do if it saw the virus
in real life
and so
in the history of vaccines there's never
been a long-term complication that's
manifest that hasn't first shown up in
the first two months of administration
so that was something that then many
scientists pointed to and said okay well
let's look in these first two months
very very carefully we've seen the trial
data tens of thousands of people in
randomized controlled trials that were
actually very well done
but
the bigger trial was the real world
right so what's actually happening what
are we being told and what are we not
being told and are our
are
our
surveillance methods actually were are
they working right because people talk
about vares which is the u.s big
database that's a hypothesis generator
it's designed to say is there something
going on that we need to investigate
further but there are other databases
that are much more rigorous like the um
vsd i think it is the vaccine safety
database from cdc and prism from uh the
fda that actually do a much more
rigorous job of looking at people who
are vaccinated people who aren't
vaccinated comparing and on an ongoing
basis now
what they found actually early on
starting with israeli data was these
reports of myocarditis they had a few
cases in the trials but it didn't look
like they were above what you would
expect in the background rate or in
placebo well add in
in a very rare like when you have rare
stuff you need hundreds of thousands of
millions of people to see it actually
show up at a scale that you can actually
say okay this is the percentage that
it's happening myocarditis we started to
catch that and it actually was caught
relatively early and what was
interesting is since it was
it's such an age-dependent thing like
it's the 12 to 17 year olds that seem to
be at the peak risk you didn't really
see it manifest a lot until we started
going down in age right so this is
important it was caught it's understood
but not perfectly in other words there's
some uncertainty like how many people
who get myocarditis would ever have
long-term damage
because if you look at other causes of
myocarditis they can cause long-term
long-term damage but the reason is often
because they involve massive viral
infection they involve other
reasons to get which is heart
inflammation and pericarditis
inflammation of the sac around the heart
but with the vaccine
we feel it's an immune reaction that's
relatively transient so we think it
should be fully reversible but again we
don't know fully so then parents should
be given this information to say okay
now you can make an educated choice
here's your child's risk of disease in
this environment with this circulating
virus and their risk of being
hospitalized and here's their risk of
myocarditis
why would we mandate a vaccine for
children when you could just tell
parents here the risks and benefits
educate them clearly and let them make a
decision for their child because
children are not the predominant vector
of this disease and they're not the ones
that are you know filling up the icus at
least not yet right in some apocryphal
news stories to the contrary so
this myocarditis is the biggest thing
that we saw with mrna and they're really
the menstrual thing
from the beginning i was saying hey
we've got to study this
because
this makes sense because
the women
are complicated like they have this
right
every time you know people will ask me
like gynecological questions and i'm
like i don't know [ __ ] about the women
parts and i studied it all in medical
school and i still have no idea how they
all fit together and how they work and
my wife will confirm that so the the
point being like the immune system
affects the hypothalamic pituitary all
the axis that controls and modulates
menstrual cycles in women
that's enough to actually cause
disruption in a cycle or two with a
profound immune response for example
just an illness covet itself or any
other viral illness can cause those
menstrual irregularities you don't have
to invoke ovarian damage like say robert
malone invoked in the last piece that he
did which actually was based on
incorrect that's not true
right that was based on
mouse data where they injected super
mouse it's not superhuman super mouse
amounts super murine that's the medical
term amounts of this
lipid nanoparticle and of course it
accumulates everywhere including in
ovaries but there was no tissue damage
and in humans we haven't seen that but
what we do see is these menstrual
irregularities nih is funding to the
tune of like 1.6 million or something
research in that and oregon just came
out with one of the results and they
were saying yeah it does appear for a
period or two there can be minor
reversible disruption in in menstrual
cycles now that doesn't mean that women
aren't really affected by that and it
doesn't cause a lot of um
fear and and that can actually feed on
itself too right so you do need to talk
about this and study it and disclose it
because otherwise who's going to trust
you if suddenly all these women are
saying but this is what i'm seeing right
um
so that's the menstrual piece now the
and any questions or i can talk about
the footage there's one thing that i
want to ask and i feel this is very
important as a layman could you please
explain what myocarditis is because it's
a term that's used again and again and
it's got to the point where i if i even
questioned it or i even asked what it is
i'd feel kind of ignorant
like now
dude there are a lot of doctors who
don't know [ __ ] about myocarditis
because we rarely ever see it
unless you're a cardiologist or a
specialist or a hospitalist like me
you'll see patients admitted with so
this is what this is
myocardium is a fancy way of saying
heart muscle
pericardium simply means the sac around
the heart what this is really is there's
myocarditis which simply itis means
inflammation so it's inflammation of the
heart muscle and
myopericarditis is inflammation of the
heart muscle and the sac around the
heart and pericarditis is just
inflammation of the sac around the heart
and what this
often causes is symptoms like chest pain
because that can be
the inflammation can cause pain it can
cause
weakening of the heart muscle so that
you don't squeeze as well that's a kind
of heart failure that is usually
reversible but it can be permanent in
causes of myocarditis that are not due
to say something like a vaccine we think
and
it can
cause enough symptoms like swelling in
the lower body and so on because the
heart's not pumping blood forward so it
backs up into the lungs and listen guys
if this sounds scary to you that's
because myocarditis
is kind of scary
like it's okay to go dude that's a
concern
like when the mainstream is like yeah
but it's mild and reversible and they
only the kids only spend a few days in
the hospital and they're better
i don't want my kid in the hospital at
all like can we talk so let's really
talk about that go okay so what if they
get coveted what's that like for them
what's so those are reasonable
conversations to have now well zubin you
sorry oh go for i thought you'd finish i
got nothing all right cool so very much
on that front what that says to me is
like there are some people like you who
are being honest about it and
acknowledging that it's likely transient
that it's a very minor thing that covet
is more likely in most cohorts to give
you similar levels of compli like all of
that is i get it right
the problem i have is the moment you
start using state compulsion or
social pressure or mandates or any sort
of form of
soft or hard coercion to tell somebody
to take an injection that can in a small
minority of cases give them what you
described as a scary thing or for women
it's menstrual changes now look
women like you know you talked about me
not having a clue about this stuff
absolutely correct a lot of people are
not medically trained and they're just
going my body a very very key function
of my body
is you know i haven't had a period for
20 years i've been through the menopause
now i've got vaginal bleeding again like
i'm not sure when when you say to me
that's transient people are gonna i'd be
like well is it how do you know that
have we done long-term studies on this
so
to me what you're saying is
these things are very unlikely most
likely transient but to me what you've
just said completely rules out any sort
of form of social compulsion being
applied to people to take this vaccine
because that risk is there and i don't
think the state should be doing that
what do you say to that
this is great because
i agree with you
and i'll tell you a situation where i
wouldn't agree with you so
let's say that that this was a vaccine
that in order to protect
children from a disease that really can
harm them
a lot to prevent the transmission of the
disease you needed to vaccinate 95
percent of kids
to generate a herd immunity that
protects the most vulnerable children
those who are too young to be vaccinated
or to have other issues that
disallow them from being vaccinated and
to
accommodate for vaccine failure because
no vaccine is perfect so even in a
cohort of vaccinated people we see it
now with covet you get infected and you
can still get sick and die so how do you
overcome that you need 95 plus
compliance with vaccine in order to
protect children
in which case mandates
which we have in the u.s for childhood
vaccines actually are the only way you
can accomplish that because
there's enough sort of hesitance in the
population that they just simply they
won't do it just out of laziness or
they'll miss an appointment or they'll
have some other exemption that they
don't want to do it so it works like
those mandates actually for childhood
vaccines do work
now with covid
you have a disease that
disproportionately affects adults where
the vaccine lowers transmission a little
bit
but not enough to say you're going to
generate herd immunity by vaccinating
you know 90 of people you'll generate
herd protection against severe disease
but even then there's a 10 failure
because the vaccines are even less
perfect right
and you have a complication potentially
that can put a child in the hospital in
which case
mandatory state mandates for that are
insane to me they're insane i agree with
you a thousand percent but again with
the caveat that i do think there are
instances where they do
have a place and that's my bias right
because i want the most people to be
safe as and look if if this was [ __ ]
ebola
and it was as transmissible as omicron
it would be i'm not saying i would
necessarily agree but it's a different
conversation this is not that right
let's just be clear about that and also
we know that the vaccine you know what
it definitely does very well is it
massively reduces your risk of being
seriously ill right so if you feel that
you're vulnerable you can take it to be
protected right you don't need to inject
five-year-olds
i am i am with you now what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna play devil's advocate for a
second right because one of the things
and this is this is my only complaint
about robin rogan
platforming guys like malone and
mccullough is and he's talked about this
recently on a show he did with the
comedian tim
he said look man like i platform
people that are on the opposite side
like i had you know rhonda patrick on i
had peter hotez on early on i had uh
osterhome on mike osterhom on those were
months ago and he often will and sanjay
gupta which was just that was just
theater really but at least they had a
conversation
he doesn't go hard on on mccullough and
malone but he goes very hard on those
other guys so it's important to platform
somebody and really
also say okay well what's the devil's
advocate and really push on that i think
that's an important thing to do you
don't have to it's his platform but so
let me let me give you the pushback on
the five-year-old mandate right so um or
or vaccinating five-year-olds
the argument would be and this comes
from pediatricians who take care of sick
patients in hospitals they see
in these kids that end up in the
hospital about a third of them have not
a lot of co-morbidities but their entire
family is unvaccinated so they're
probably getting a high viral inoculum
from the parents not the other way
around and they're coming in and for
whatever reason they're vulnerable they
end up on a ventilator and
some of them get very sick and some of
them die but either way they suffer a
lot in the hospital
then that same pediatrician will look at
the studies in like say the san
francisco bay area where there's
cocooning where all the adults are
vaccinated and even before the kids
could get vaccinated
kids weren't showing up in the hospital
and now the kids are getting vaccinated
there's a high penetrance in the bay
area not a lot of kids are showing up in
the hospital with coven and they'll go
well there it is so clearly we can save
some children's lives at a very small
cost of myocarditis which we also see
but it seems to get better they get out
of the hospital so that's their
viewpoint
i actually disagree with that viewpoint
because i think it's an emotional
viewpoint they're seeing because they're
seeing this stuff what they're not
seeing is the area under the curve of
the societal disruption the compulsion
the stress on parents who feel they're
being compelled to do something the
authoritarian sort of slide into this is
now okay to do for things that that are
lycoved where does it end and um again i
i i so i agree with you there but that
would be the pushback i see yeah well
the the pushback from to the pushback
for me would be
the opening of that door is like you're
allowed to feed your kid to death
right
so do we want to mandate you know diet
or like how where do you go with this uh
that's the door that worries me being
opened it's interesting because that
does dovetail right into the question of
like man and rogan brings this up a lot
and he gets accused of fat shaming and
things like that but basically what he's
saying is look can we talk about the
obesity epidemic that's actually caused
america to be pure dry tinder for this
pandemic like in thin younger
populations like in africa they do much
better but here we're a bunch of fat
lazy [ __ ] who you know sit in front of
the tv
and so what happens this disease is
perfectly designed to cull the herd like
it it hurts the elderly and it hurts
people who are who are who are obese and
have chronic disease it's often
secondary to obesity or lifestyle choice
not always so
what do we do about like do you treat
them with the same scarlet letter you
know
it becomes this very complex dynamic and
then it gets to the root of like do we
even have free will like are these
people even making choices or are they
the reflection of something larger
that's feeding back to them unconscious
processes conditioning genetics
education all that um
and and that's where it just becomes i
always err on the libertarian side where
i'm like you know what give people as
much education as you can have policies
that prevent us from yelling fire in a
theater or burning down a building but
other than that you really have to take
the fact that a lot of humans are still
figuring [ __ ] out and let it be you know
yeah and so you use the example of
africa and the pushback that i always
say is but then why is south america so
badly affected around about a third of
all covert deaths are in south america
and with the exception of a few
a very small percentage of the
population
south america has deep levels of poverty
so this is interesting and i again we
don't have an answer for this but i
would say there's a couple of
interesting pieces here
africa may also have a lot of exposure
to natural coronaviruses that come out
of asia so that's one theory is they
have some pre-existing t-cell immunity
the second is
levels of activity may be higher in
africa but the third is
the population of folks in south america
tend to genetically have predispositions
towards insulin resistance and metabolic
syndrome so if you look at say for
example the even the mexican population
that comes to the u.s they are diabetic
hypertensive obese because they're
eating a western diet and i think what
we're seeing in south america is the
westernization of the diet
these folks have more metabolic syndrome
and they're more at risk than you would
think there's a condition called skinny
fat
it's a
sort of lay term for this idea that
people can not can look skinny but
actually be very metabolically unwell
have a lot of fat in their around their
intestines and stuff that's
metabolically inflammatory and that
inflammatory setup i had a doctor on the
show called uh ron sinha who speaks to
this that inflammatory setup is like
again more kindling for kovit to just
cause the cytokine storm that lands
people in the hospital one other point
on that so brazil that has these huge
death rates they use a lot of ivermectin
and again i think it goes to show that
you can't look at kind of observational
data to make a decision on something
like ivermectin you really because it's
conflicting you really need to do a good
randomized control trial
and that being the case subin we know
that why is the government not putting
out
adverts saying look if you're morbidly
obese you are in real danger with this
illness you're gonna need to lose weight
it's that simple why are we not doing
that why are we not encouraging people
to eat better why do we shut gyms
this is one of the great failures of
western medicine in general is we love
we get paid
this is something where i'm very
sympathetic to malone and malone's point
that like hey you know even the way we
medically code things i don't think
there's massive fraud going on with
covid coding but i do think he's
absolutely right to point out incentives
right
so
we are paid to fix the problems of
obesity and all that and our public
health funding to prevent those problems
is very small and there's a lot of
skepticism in public health circles even
that it can be done because the
availability of shitty food in the
poorest areas of the country in urban
areas etc is ubiquitous but you can't
get fresh produce and that kind of thing
it's more expensive so
often these diseases are diseases of
poverty like in rural mississippi
everybody's massively obese because all
they're eating is the cheapest most
available food which is terrible
education levels are lower as you so
wealth and education correlate to longer
life spans and why is that well
we might be able to afford i'm going to
put myself in the rich category because
i'm upper middle class like we might be
able to afford you know a nice uh uh
meal with fresh produce and all of that
and cook it and then go out to eat at
nicer restaurants and have our one glass
of wine and not overdo it and not drink
a 10 pack of beer and all that but
somebody who's a single
mother working multiple jobs got to feed
her kids and do all this that's not an
option right and so what do they do what
do we do we don't talk about it we don't
teach about it we close schools where
kids were getting decent
nutrition and education and exercise and
instead we put them in a house until i'm
locked down
and we have actually set this population
of vulnerables back by an order of
magnitude and by the way they're the
ones delivering our our food for the
rich zoomocracy that can sit here at
home and tisk wear a mask on our avatar
and complain and then now omicron's the
great equalizer and all those [ __ ]
are getting it too and now they're like
well i guess it's okay to get covered we
might as well just let it go
it's like [ __ ] you know
well i i want to get to omicron in in a
second but uh sticking again sort of
with the medical questions for you
um you know one of the things that
people obviously have advanced about
questioning the safety of the vaccines
is the idea that of spike protein
toxicity right and what i'd be curious
about zoom because ordinary people like
me and francis and many of the people
watching this and listening to this now
we have no way of assessing whether that
claim is true now
i would argue that if if the vaccine was
toxic and it was killing or maiming lots
of people
that has to show up somewhere right it
has to show up in hospital admissions it
has to show up in databases and whatever
now i'm sure there's ways for that to
not be counted quite right or whatever
but like how would we if that were
happening how would we know that it was
happening
yeah it's a great question and by the
way do not let me forget to address the
footballers dropping dead thing yes yeah
why don't you do that first and then
we'll get to the spike okay great yeah
so let me just remember this question
it's about spike protein toxicity how
would we know
safety in that okay good so the
footballer thing is interesting um
i actually
dug into this a little bit more so that
idea that
elite uh footballers are dropping dead
about 108 or so not dead not dead having
having seizures a lot of them are a few
are dropping dead but a lot of them are
having some kind of collapse on the
field due to their heart issues
okay so
the piece that i was seeing that was the
most prevalent was the idea that people
were having cardiac arrest and dropping
on the field right so not necessarily a
seizure per se
seizure is probably the wrong word uh
some some elite athletes are dying with
cardiac issues right and many more elite
athletes are either collapsing with
cardiac issues or are showing cardiac
issues in testing that football clubs
often do and are then being prevented
from playing elite sport forever because
they have a new heart issue that they
didn't have before that is the
allegation i don't know whether it's
true but that is what what we're being
told
interesting okay so i have not seen the
data
on that aspect of it the non-fatal
aspect of it right but i have seen the
data on the fatal aspect because
remember this started somewhere right
this idea that this is happening it
came to the fore kind of like when you
do vaccine surveillance and you see
blood clots in the johnson and johnson
vaccine which we'll talk about how is
that detected right so this was not
detected in
vaccine database screening so they were
not seeing this so where they were
seeing this was there was an israeli
alternative news article that said hey
about 108 of these elite athletes have
died presumably and most of them have
cardiac issues they reviewed news
reports etc
since the vaccine was released and so
you know i'll let you decide what that
is it's
and the assumption is it's likely
vaccine-related myocarditis causing a
rhythm abnormalities and heart damage
and that sort of thing and it makes boy
it makes intuitive sense because you're
like yeah if you have myocarditis and
you don't diagnose it and you go out and
exercise
a lot you can trigger
a
arrhythmia a heart rhythm problem and
and that can be fatal if it's not
treated right away with an automated
defibrillator advice device so
this is quite compelling well when you
actually look at where that so and then
that started spreading through the
neuronal network of the antithesis tribe
through places like bit shoot and rumble
and all of that those are kind of the
transmitter nodes and pretty soon it
became like wait now what's going on
here
so
mainstream tribe then tries to look at
that and they go away well so what's
going on uh because that would be a
serious concern turns out a lot of the
the athletes that were looked at in that
were not necessarily football players so
they were athletes of all kinds
including coaches
and caddies and golf and those kind of
things and of all ages and all sexes
so
really unlikely that myocardius was
there and then they went back and said
wait some of them actually predated the
vaccine and a lot of them in the news
reports it was actually
figured out that they had some
congenital thing or something else and
there were three cases where the
question of vaccine
relation to it actually did arise and it
wasn't resolved so when then you look
back and you talk to say
there was a charity that represents in
great britain
in the uk
uh young kids who have congenital heart
abnormalities like that
can promote arrhythmias and sudden
cardiac death
they said in 2008 there was a study that
said 12 of these folks would die
every week would collapse every week in
the uk alone
so if you look at that sort of trend as
background you can then start to listen
to what the major sports associations
medical departments were saying in
response to this article which was we're
not seeing anything above and beyond
what we would expect to see
normally now with this newer information
i don't know i'd have to look at that
data to see where that's coming from but
that's okay
yeah
all right so let's go to the spike
protein toxicity which kind of ties into
this whole thing anyway
yeah so this thing okay
one thing to remember is
in the original trials these were what
40 000 people in the arms and so on and
you're looking for
complications and again in the history
of vaccines we see things show up in the
first two months that doesn't mean
something new can't happen right so
this is what they saw and this is where
i think malone is being a little
disingenuous when he says
or pfizer never got approved never
studied the safety of their spike
protein except that they did in the
massive randomized control trial and the
other thing that he says that's
incorrect is there was never
pre-clinical studies animals and all
that they are there are and they're
available online and you can look at
them
but the
the bigger point here is
is the spike protein produced by the
vaccine toxic and this has been
something you know byron bridal and
um
i forget who else is saying this kind of
thing it's been a big trope in the
antithesis tribe that this thing is
toxic so why would we want to
induce our body to make it
well
in those trials they saw none of the
toxicities that are described to spike
protein toxicities like major heart
damage ovarian failure liver and kidney
failure we've seen none of that none of
that in the trials okay fine so what
about the real world we see none of that
so the ongoing surveillance we don't see
it and in the real world so
and and then i'm gonna i'm gonna talk
about too about johnson johnson in the
real world in like let's look at my you
know bastion of liberaldom on earth it's
like you know queen galadriel here with
her you know ring applying communism
where i live that's what it feels like
but everybody's vaccinated so it's 81
general penetrance of vaccine and that
includes children who cannot be
vaccinated so it's even higher in people
who are eligible for vaccine
all these vaccinated people uh all
different ages i know every single
hospital here and i talk to everybody we
see
none of the things surging that
the malones and others would say we
ought to be seeing and that they claim
they are seeing we are not seeing it so
on the ground not seeing it now what we
do see is some kovid but not that much
here and we're seeing sort of
asymptomatic and minimally symptomatic
omicron so we're just not seeing that
now what about actual surveillance so
here's where i think
and again maybe i'm biased because i
don't think that all these entities are
poisoned by conflict as much as say a
malone or mccullough might say because
it's also a very convenient thing to say
it's like well whatever data you give me
i'm just going to say that it's poisoned
by conflict for example if reuters does
a fact-checking thing well reuters board
sits on pfizer's board so of course
they're going to say that well so here's
what's interesting johnson and johnson
and related to it astrazeneca the one
that's more used in uk
this vaccine major pharmaceutical
company not just a pharmaceutical
company a multinational conglomerate
they make everything from baby powder to
band-aids to whatever it is they make
right huge company
if there is a global conspiracy
to hide vaccine complications and
promote vaccination
johnson johnson did not get the memo
because
their vaccine early on there were cases
reported of very unusual blood clotting
the cerebral venous sinus thrombosis and
things like that this happens in the
background population very rarely so
very quickly the standard screening
databases picked this up and it got
jumped on to the degree where they
actually paused the rollout of the
vaccine which actually caused
irreparable harm to the vaccine in
general
and this got pounded on everybody was
talking about it everybody was looking
at it we were talking about okay what
age group does it happen and what's the
risk and because we had another vaccine
i think they were more even more
aggressive about it if it was the only
vaccine i don't think they would have
paused it they would have said here's
the risks you guys know now we still
think you should get it which is
basically what they said but they never
would have paused it so it got caught it
got looked at and
it and i think that was a very rare
event so events where spike protein is
clearly toxic you would see it and you
would see it across every vaccine
because all those spike proteins are
being produced are that wild type wuhan
spike protein so we just don't see it in
practice now could there be something
we're missing sure i think
it'd be very unlikely and again this may
be some of my medical bias showing up
because we've just never seen it before
but i i think it's pretty compelling so
far
zubin isn't the problem as well is that
a lot of people don't trust
pharmaceutical companies and for many
reasons
they actually have a point if you look
at the opioid crisis in america
that has been created
by the pharmaceutical company so when
they see them rolling you know
rolling out vaccines
and being urged to take it you can't
blame people for going well i don't want
anything to do with it particularly if
you come from a from communities which
have been decimated by the by the crisis
i think see this is interesting because
there's
there's a there's a feeling in the
mainstream that they want to defend
pharmaceutical companies as great
saviors of mankind right nobody's able
to actually speak with nuance on
pharmaceuticals and here's my take on
pharmaceuticals and i've done like music
video parodies making fun of
pharmaceutical companies but i still get
called a shill
by you know hardcore antithesis tribe
members in any video i make so
the big pharmaceutical companies are an
epi phenomenon they're an emergent
property of a capitalist marketplace
that
that is a not really capitalist it's a a
kind of a oligopoly so these huge
huge entities that are actually molded
by the regulations and the regulators
that manage them in this dynamic way
that then creates an oligopoly because
the only people that can afford to get
drugs to market are these massive
bureaucratic machines
they themselves are poisonous
horrible entities because you have the
marketing side that's pushing to
consumers drugs that would be better
avoided when you can just eat well
exercise spend that money on
education and food
um and gyms and those kind of things
and just horrible business practices
they're a bunch of liars they're
manipulators absolutely
awful human beings on that side right
then you get to the research and
development side these are the people
that i know i have a lot of friends in
these departments they are
there to help humans they're amazing
scientists doctors pharmacists nurses
that work in these companies and they're
the ones that are driving the engine of
innovation right it's the other ones
that totally [ __ ] it up so
and the opioid thing was it was a great
tale of how incredibly evil these
companies can behave due to profit
motive so yeah we ought to be absolutely
suspicious that's why when i listen to
malone talk about that that's when i'm
like my brother i'm with you like
everything you're saying is resonating
with me like i'm ready to storm the
bastille right and um and at the same
time like we would have to form a fence
around those researchers that are doing
the hard work and the some of the
smaller companies that are trying and
it's just the incentives have to change
you know like it's it's insane and of
course the regulators are the
pharmaceutical guys are the regulators
it there is that capture it is
absolutely real and at the same time the
federal
food and drug administration is a
massive bureaucracy that's that actually
slows down the approval of drugs that
actually might help and speeds up drugs
that don't work like at helm which was
an alzheimer's drug they finally had to
back off and and they finally said today
hey medicare said in the united states
what funds are medicine says we're not
paying for this for most people because
it doesn't work no matter what fda said
where they were so influenced by the
pharma you know biogen the
pharmaceutical so you should be
suspicious of that [ __ ]
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
i was gonna say as well the problem for
me is that
when you when we talk about things like
spike proteins or all this other stuff
so
i have got no experience in science
really
i stopped studying science in when i was
16 and i and i had an arts based
education right the the problem for me
is this i watched
a very good documentary about flat
earthers and they were talking to these
to this uh he found it very persuasive
yeah it was it was great
it's great you know it's not round it's
flat it makes sense the ground is a
conspiracy the world is flat it's total
common sense yeah yeah but but this is
the point and i've mentioned that do
this in other interviews they
interviewed this nasa scientist and it
always stuck with me she went the reason
these people believe that
is the fault of the scientists because
we are not transmitting the educa the
information to them in a manner that a
layman would be able to understand so
actually every time they're saying this
stuff it's a fault of me and my peers
and by the way just to add very briefly
to that zubin as well i think part of it
is
presenting information in a way that
people can understand but i think with
covet it's also partly presenting
information in a way that people can
accept
and that's the piece that i think a lot
of people who do what you do pretty well
there are other people who maybe have
the same medical expertise and they can
come in and they can explain why some of
the antithesis stuff is not true but
they're doing it with with a sort of
disdain and they're going oh this malone
character and they spend hours on
twitter debunking his qualifications i
don't care about robert malone's
qualifications i care if he's telling
the truth or not that's all i care about
you know what i mean
you've put your finger on my biggest
my biggest beef with my own tribe which
are and i'm just going to speak honestly
now for a second doctors are the [ __ ]
worst they are the worst they are the
most captured hive mind inertia driven
fear-driven creatures and it's not their
fault it's because their education
instills in them from day one kiss the
ring of the authority figure the
attending physician the consulting
physician so one day in return you'll be
the ring that is kissed don't rock the
boat because you could kill someone and
if you open your mouth you're going to
get hammered down by the establishment
that is how we're trained the public is
right to question us they are right to
push back but the problem is they're in
their own hive mind because they've been
conditioned to believe that there's a
pill or a magic bullet for everything so
they feed the pharma monster and they
feed into physicians who then are like
well this patient's going to rip me a
new one on you know whatever uh doctor
rating platform if i don't give them the
opioid or don't give them the antibiotic
for their virus that's not going to help
and it becomes this vicious thing so
doctors on twitter are the worst they're
captured by this blue church uh thesis
idea that everybody outside of that is
stupid they're flat earthers and they're
dumb and they need to be they need to
shut up or be forced to do what they're
going to do how's that going to work
because actually when you talk to people
on the antithesis side they're
hyper-intelligent they're very curious
yeah they're captured in their own way
absolutely but we all are so how do you
talk to them well first of all you have
to have a dialogue that's respectful and
actually recognize their moral
foundation where they're coming from
like you said it has to not just be
accurate it has to be acceptable
why do people distrust pharmaceuticals
say in the antithesis tribe apart from
the obvious well they have a what
jonathan height
social psychologist calls a moral
foundation a moral matrix different
taste buds than say somebody in the blue
church on the left would have so blue
church values fairness versus cheating
care versus harm those moral palates
well then of course they're going to
want vaccinate as many people as you can
mask up stay home protect the vulnerable
but it turns out antithesis tribe
conservatives in general libertarians in
general
have more of those taste buds spread out
further so liberty versus oppression
authority versus subversion loyalty
versus betrayal sanctity versus
degradation which is a very powerful one
like are you really going to tell me
what to put in my body right and whereas
it's interesting on the on the blue
church side the thesis side
sanctity versus degradation manifest
says these filthy unvaccinateds are
going to come and make my family sick
with their you know delta so you can see
how good people trying to be morally
good based on what they have what their
condition genetic educated et cetera
can see the world entirely differently
so what scientists need to do is
recognize that go these are bubbles okay
how do we form if this is the left
hemisphere and this is the right
hemisphere and they're each hive minds
of their own if you cut the connection
between those hemispheres as ian
mcgilchrist researcher has said these
behave as separate in a human we have
two separate individuals vying for each
other left side right side they do
different things they think differently
they see the world differently well
what normally prevents that is this
corpus callosum these neural fibers that
connect the hemispheres scientists
educators communicators should be those
fibers they should be the the this alt
middle as i call it hive mind that says
yes and to all these sides and how can
we speak in a way that's respectful and
understands the moral matrix underlying
it and speaks to it but we don't do that
we we hive mind off we're all guilty of
it i'm guilty of it especially early
covet i was like you know i think i
reviewed a video pandemic and my review
my review was basically this is [ __ ]
stupid anyone who believes this is an
idiot i can't even believe i'm spending
my time like spit was coming out of my
mouth i'm pounding the table he gets
three million views on youtube
ninety percent of the comments are
antithesis people that are like you're a
tool you bald clown you look like
somebody said he looks like
dwayne the rock johnson with end stage
aids and i was like
that's pretty good
that's pretty good that is a good take
though
so it doesn't work
yeah no it doesn't work and i think i've
seen the evolution in your work and i
think that's why we really wanted to
have you on the show because i think
it's very effective uh i know we're
probably running slightly over are you
okay to do a few a few more questions
i'm down i'm down to clown for however
long you need me amazing man i really
appreciate that so you mentioned there
the sort of thesis blue church tribe and
one of the arguments from them that i
was curious to get your take on is
the idea that you must get vaccinated
not because like it's herd immunity or
whatever but because you are the petri
dish for new variants to mutate in is
that true
yeah that's elite [ __ ]
and the reason is that the petri dish
for new variants to emerge is the
developing world where we've not done
the courtesy of giving them a first dose
when we're talking about third and
fourth doses in rich countries it's
insanity if you want to prevent variants
you prevent viral replication and the
thing is in the end the variants may be
emerging in animals they may be emerging
in immunocompromised people who are
actually
going to replicate virus whether they're
vaccinated or not
and now you could make the argument that
if you vaccinate the whole population
there's less circulating virus less
likely they're going to get infected
that's all true but it requires
a lot of abstraction to get to that
point so i think that is a very tribal
statement it's a badge of identity in
that group and it doesn't serve very
much good at all in the world okay and
then
look i've
one of the theories about omicron which
we're going to get to in a second and
obviously the the og coveted as well
is so first of all the lablet hypothesis
about the original virus coming from a
lab in wuhan and also there are people
like yuri dagan i don't know if you're
familiar with him i know yuri
you know yuri so i've been talking to
yuri quite a bit recently uh and one of
the things he's talking about is omicron
in his opinion
there's some i know i don't get it and i
think we talked about it in the episode
that you watched of us
the idea is it came through mice and
that points to a lab in durban in south
africa and blah blah blah so where are
you on those two things
so i'm not an expert in that i can say
this that the theories on that are
yuri's theory there's the theory that it
actually emerged in a in an animal
because there are so many mutations and
it's so divergent from the delta strain
that
uh it may have emerged in an animal the
other theory is that it emerged much
earlier and was circulating somewhere
quietly but that's hard to believe
because it's so contagious it would have
taken over quite uh rapidly and the
third one is that it emerged in a um
immunocompromised host where you can get
infected and the virus and just keep
replicating but it doesn't actually
cause a lot of disease because the
disease is caused by the immune system's
reaction and so they're just viral
factories and it happened there even
that one's a tough one right it's hard
to know so i don't know if yuri's right
or wrong if if yuri's right again that's
just more
concern about gain of function research
like why are we doing this now right now
it's interesting now i'm going to play
devil's advocate for myself because i'm
in the gain of function are you high
like why would you do that
the arguments for gain of function
research are that
first of all the public doesn't
understand the spectrum of gain of
function there are aspects of gain of
function where you do minor things to
things in order to
create studyable environments and you
actually can't do it any other way well
that's rare and even in those cases
you'd need egregious controls on escape
and i honestly just don't think it's
worth it because if this were a lab leak
right
i mean come on we've destroyed our
social fabric i'm not going to say we
destroyed the world because look dude
it's an infection fatality rate of 0.2
to 0.3 a whole bunch of people died but
we did not destroy the world this isn't
an asteroid but we destroyed our
cohesion we've further tribalized and
we've cost i don't know how many
billions of dollars in untold suffering
so
you know something needs to be held
accountable for that we can't have it
repeat but yeah i don't know the answer
and i was going to move on to omicron
yeah
so
so
the question that i wanted to ask
particularly with omicron is a lot
there's a lot of people saying
omicron signals the end of the pandemic
is that something that you agree with
so every time i've said x signals the
end of the pandemic i've been wrong
it does make me start to want to be part
of the antithesis tribe and feel like
i'm actually being picked on by fauci
like every time i say something i feel
like fauci or somebody is watching and
they're like okay release the omicron
you know or release the delta because
it's just it's that uncanny so this this
is my take on omicron i've done a couple
videos on this um
here's the possibility and i think it's
it's more likely than not but that
doesn't mean it's not wrong so omicron
is highly infectious very contagious but
it causes less severe disease in most
people unless you're vulnerable and
still as you guys recognize right
less severe disease simply means it's
more like flu
you don't get hospitalized but it still
[ __ ] sucks like you guys went
especially it sounds like um francis
went through hell with that
and
so
what it does then is since it has a
reproductive number in other words each
person who's infected infects x number
of people that's your r naught your
reproductive number that's high it's
like close to 10 or something that's
almost in measles territory it means
that
your your ability to mitigate this virus
to actually prevent it from spreading
with your standard approach of cloth
diaper on your face and like
you know stay home for a couple days is
not going to work everybody's going to
get it and it's going to be very very
fast and because it's so fast it's going
to tear through vulnerables very quickly
and then it's probably going to come
down really fast and what you're going
to be left with is a population that has
mixed immunity vaccine immunity natural
immunity previously from delta and wuhan
strain and from omicron
people who've been boosted by getting
breakthrough infections from either
natural infection like you guys had or
vaccine in fact vaccine-induced immunity
now with omicron and now you have a
population that is in much better shape
for the next wave of whatever happens
whether it's a resurgence of omicron or
a different variant and the truth is
that's what probably happens when we get
a new cold virus because over time when
it's first introduced everybody dies i
mean everybody meaning there's a
population that just gets really sick
other people don't get that sick and
then you develop immunity and then the
whole population moves forward so that
every season people get reinfected
because this is an important thing
people don't really understand this
point
this particular virus is a respiratory
virus that replicates very rapidly we'll
pick on omicron in particular
in the upper airways
it as part of its disease process it
does not need to enter the bloodstream
and cause what they call viremia
meaning virus in the blood it doesn't
need to do that it can do that later in
the disease but really it causes this
massive immune response that's how
causes severe disease and then it can
get into the blood later and cause worse
disease well what do vaccines and even
to some degree natural immunity do they
generate
antibodies that live mostly in the blood
some of them live in the mucosal
membranes but mostly in the blood so you
can get infected that's why this early
talk of like hey look at this 90 they're
not even getting infected well that was
early strain that replicates very slowly
but with omicron it's like dude you're
already infected before they the virus
has even seen an antibody but what is
what do the antibodies do they get spun
up really quickly because body
recognizes virus goes okay activate the
memory b cells you know like release the
hounds the next thing you know you've
got protection in the blood against
severe disease meaning hospitalizable
disease in most people so within the
variation of the population some people
just don't mount that immune response no
matter what you do
and that's why i think omicron is the
great equalizer everybody's been
vaccinated everybody hasn't been
vaccinated most of them are just going
to get infected it's going to take away
the stigma of covid it's going to
generate a lot of immunity and it's
going to push us towards a phase where
this is more like a cold
i've argued that we're already in the
phase where every single societal
mandate and restriction should be
removed there should be no vaccine
passports there should be no mandates
there should be no mask mandates every
single individual can make a decision
now and say okay if i want to protect
myself against omicron i have to wear an
n95 mask i will do that i will get
vaccinated and boosted fine or i don't
want to do that and you not doing that
is not really going to move the curve on
other people except maybe you'll fill up
a hospital because
this is true 90 of people that are dying
in hospital are still unvaccinated in
the united states it's a big number
right now that'll shift as more people
get vaccinated because then the
breakthroughs will be the only people
dying
may i interrupt very briefly and please
correct me if i'm wrong i think
that obviously that is true
statistically speaking but i think what
that misrepresents is the age groups
because people throw that stat out to
make it sound like unvaccinated people
are at huge risk what we're actually
talking about is unvaccinated people who
are in their 60s and 70s who maybe have
a few co-morbidities they are really in
the [ __ ] but if you are a 20 year old
and you are vaccinated you're not going
to be dying in an icu statistically
speaking would that be fair to say with
omicron i think it's absolutely fair to
say it's even more fair to say with
omicron because omicron is so generally
milder and again i use that word mild
people get very butt hurt when i use
that word because they've had it and
they're like no this sucks or they're in
a hospital and they see someone sick
with it it's true now the one caveat to
that is a lot of young people remember i
talked about that skinny fat thing
earlier like why is it that south
americans a lot of young people don't
realize how [ __ ] up they are
nutritionally and
they are actually more at risk than they
think that's why i generally advocate
young people get vaccinated but if they
don't want to that's cool too um but yes
you're right it is
can we really
let's really say this clearly for the
people in the back
this is a disease
in which the vast majority of people who
are fall ill and die
or get very bad complications are older
than 65 or older than 50 with multiple
comorbidities this is a fact and i think
when we treat this like it's some
childhood disease right that needs to be
stamped out of every single human we're
doing the policy a disservice because
now you're wielding a policy hammer that
doesn't apply to this particular disease
and we've been saying that from like day
one thank god this doesn't you know kill
masses of children it's still that's not
to discount the children who've suffered
and have died and the misc and these
kind of unusual syndromes they are real
but they're not a reason to shut down
all of society we don't do that for
influenza we don't do that for rsv right
now the number one admissions in
hospitals according to paul offit in the
winter right now currently
for kids are
influenza metanewma virus
rsv and then covid
in that order
uh and he was just on this week in
virology saying this so uh if he's wrong
i'm gonna blame him but i think that i
think that feels right yeah
zubin you touched the if i may a couple
of medical questions just you touched on
natural immunity something we haven't
got around to uh but i think it's
important to talk about so as we talked
about in our video about getting covered
i will put my hand up and say i was
cavalier i was like hey we got covered
in february 2020. now we've got natural
immunity for the rest of eternity i'm
gonna be fine
uh didn't quite work out that way
however there are there are obviously a
lot of studies that show natural
immunities as good as the vaccine
certainly in terms of transmission and
stuff like that so what is the truth
about natural immunities urban versus
first of all versus the vaccine or with
the vaccine or just give us all of that
sure sure yeah the quick rundown on that
now i'm going to put a point on what you
said you said you were cavalier about
you know the thing and thinking so on
and so forth i would have been too if i
were molecule for molecule you i would
have been like
and you know what you were right you
didn't get severe disease you didn't end
up hospitalized francis at least had to
go to you know a e and get evaluated and
all that and they lied to him and told
him that he didn't have a blood clot and
at any moment he's gonna drop dead
i mean they should have just told him to
man up that's what i would have done
that's what i tell most of my p any
anyone who says they have long covet i'm
like walk it off and they're like when i
walk i get really tired we can also
address that but um
uh yeah the question of natural immunity
versus vaccine so here's the thing i
think based on the data we have and it's
a mixed data set and it depends on who
you believe cdc's data set is garbage
and that's what they're using to say
everybody should vax up and i think
that's atrocious as marty mccary said on
my show their trials would not pass a
seventh grade science projects muster
and yet you have these big data sets out
of israel and other places there's no
good reason to believe that natural
immunity shouldn't be very robust except
to say it might be variable if you had
an asymptomatic case or a minimally
symptomatic case with not a lot of viral
load you might have generated less of a
response the nice advantage of the
vaccines is that they're very prescribed
in terms of what kind of response you
get because it's a fixed dose of what
you're getting and you're getting a
booster that then allows even more
consolidation of immune response b cell
heterogeneity that allows even broader
coverage against variants that might
emerge and things like that
but i think natural immunity is very
powerful now you had it back in like the
wuhan days like when we were calling it
the china virus and all that
like those good old days right when we
could be xenophobic with our names of
the virus and no one would yell at us um
the
the um
the the issue there is your neutralizing
antibodies have waned over time which
they do even with the vaccine which
means you can get reinfected which we
talked about why you might have that
happen but again your memory protection
against severe disease is robust so
vaccine does a really good job too
it may actually not even um
require boosters in most people to
prevent severe disease right although
that may change over time especially
with pfizer pfizer's was a little bit
and and astrazeneca and johnson and
johnson as well johnson johnson really
should have been a two dose vaccine but
they tried it as a one dose and now most
people are saying you really need to get
that second dose or a dose of mrna if
you want the level of protection that
you would expect from a vaccine
pfizer is a little bit less effective
than moderna it's quite clear because
the dose is less and it's spaced closer
together three weeks the longer you
space it up to probably 12 weeks the
more robust immune response you get and
this is known with other vaccines so
probably they spaced it that close
because they were trying to get through
the trial in a way that actually showed
something and it was a pandemic and you
didn't want to leave people vulnerable
for the period after they got the first
dose
for too long so it was kind of they were
trying to figure out the sweet spot but
i think they probably got it a little
bit wrong now what's interesting with
moderna it's a higher dose so better
efficacy against both severe disease and
infection but more myocarditis so this
is what's crazy
people say we're not talking about
myocarditis but boy the europeans do not
allow do not recommend in certain
countries moderna for anyone under 30
because of the myocarditis risk we have
a safer vaccine the pfizer so this has
been really put into policy in places
other than the u.s it's a little
frustrated that hasn't that it hasn't
happened in the u.s so
i think we should respect natural
immunity stop shaming people if they say
you know what i've been infected why are
you making me get a vaccine that's crazy
it's counterproductive it's
anti-scientific and it's gonna generate
a lot of vaccine uh resentment what they
call psychological reactants where
people are like [ __ ] you this doesn't
even make sense why are you telling me
what to do you're blowing your you know
policy load on something that really is
not going to move the needle like
yeah
very briefly zoom and i totally get that
uh if you were in our position uh had
covered twice just had it for a second
time obviously had it quite badly the
second time
should people in our position get
vaccinated in your opinion and when
should they if at all
yeah this is a great question man if i
were molecule for molecule you even with
my own biases towards vaccine i would
probably wait like
12 weeks because you know you're gonna
get high neutralizing antibody levels
through that period of time you know and
at that point if you decide listen i
just don't even want to [ __ ] with covet
again like uh you know i'm just going to
take one dose of an mrna vaccine or a
single dose of astrazeneca or something
like that
that's fine i think that's totally
reasonable if you live with someone
who's very high risk and you're trying
to protect them well it will reduce your
chances of getting infected because this
is another sort of misunderstanding in
the antithesis tribe that vaccine
doesn't prevent transmission it does it
does so in two ways it prevents people
from getting infected in the first place
to some degree and then it narrows the
time that you're actually sick and
infectious now how much effect that has
in the real world probably smaller than
the blue tribe would have you or the
thesis tribe would have you
have you believe
but so that that's another reason to get
vaccinated even if you've been naturally
infected and is there a way to monitor
how immune you are at at a certain point
in time like we just had covet if we is
there a way to monitor how protected we
are is that possible
it's so shitty because all you're
measuring is neutralizing antibodies and
commercially available tests and those
are not a great proc they're they
correlate to immunity but they're not
really precise so what does 100 mean
versus 500 versus 1600 nobody really
knows they'll just say well more is
better but what we can't measure is your
memory b and t cells and those those are
not commercial those are research tests
and they're very complicated to do so in
reality it's very tough to rely on a
blood test to
determine
immunity now i would say this if you're
low risk for complications in other
words you're not a 15 year old boy
i would just err on the side of getting
a vaccine if it's even a question for
you because i think the risks are that
low based on what i've seen in the data
set now you may disagree you may say no
personally any risk is too much if i've
already this or that i'll rather do the
antibody test at least to no that's fine
too but that would be my take remember
i'm the hellraiser guy that's just full
of vaccine but i'll say this i did not
want to get a booster with moderna i was
i actually said publicly i'm not going
to get this until i feel i really want
to and then i'll explain why i did it
and i waited until i saw omicron kind of
really tearing through
and that's when i made the decision it
was in late december i said okay fine
i'm going to get this third uh moderna
which is a half dose and the reason i
decided to do it is i didn't even want
to have to get infected have symptoms
and have to quarantine that was one
thing and the second thing is i wanted
to be able to publicly report what my
symptoms were from that third dose
because moderna my second dose knocked
me on my ass like i felt like i was
dying for like a good 30 hours and then
i took some tylenol and i got better but
the third dose actually was much milder
in terms of side effects for me um so
that that's what i uh why i made that
decision
and the last question that i'm going to
ask zubin of the interview is
do you
we had dr john wyatt on the show who is
he's a retired pediatrician and he said
the worrying thing about kovid is that
we don't know the long term effects of
having covered
is that something that concerns you and
particularly touching on long covered
but also as well because he made the
point he said we don't know 20 years
time you know are we going to see all
these you know weird neurological
conditions coming up
as a result of this infection
so this is a classic example of of
uncertainty
generating a fear bias right
so it's the same same thing happens with
vaccine like we you know what we don't
know in 20 years what will happen and
it's like well we can look at other
vaccines well we can also look at other
viruses there are certain viruses like
measles for example
in rare cases that measles actually
causes brain inflammation so you get
measles as a kid
in your teens you can get this
devastating condition that's almost
invariably debilitating or fatal
this kind of encephalitis and it happens
in rare cases there was another
compelling reason to do universal
mandates for measles vaccines because
you're preventing these complications
that are fatal um in young people that
have lots of life to live with kovid we
just we it is uncertain but we can kind
of look at other coronaviruses we can
look at previous sars outbreak and
survivors of that and things like that
and make some conclusions
this idea of long effects for example
long covid
it's very interesting because we have no
idea what it is because we have no idea
what conditions like chronic fatigue
syndrome which is also called myalgic
encephalomyelitis or like fibromyalgia
are these are weird biopsychosocial
diseases meaning there's a biological
component this previous infection is a
trigger there's a psychological
component because there's often
depression anxiety other things that are
manifest and there's a social component
hey have you guys heard about this
disease go online form a support group
exchange symptoms and that is a dynamic
with every disease but with these
diseases it's much more shifted towards
an equity between the three categories
so we don't know but i'll say this this
is a great chance to study
what
viruses do in the long term because how
much of chronic fatigue syndrome is long
flu
or long epstein-barr virus long
mononucleosis um we don't know
but the the symptoms and signs are very
very similar this sort of fatigue after
exercise the brain fog
the general aches um uh depression sleep
abnormalities very very similar
so i think it's an opportunity to study
because we honestly don't know anyone
who says they know the answer this is
they're making [ __ ] up by the way i
heard something on i don't know if it
was that guy on your show or somebody
else on a recent show that was saying
it's clear
since
coronavirus causes smell and taste loss
okay so i disagree with him here and
i'll tell you why
he said that was a reason that it's
clear that the virus enters the brain
and therefore is going to cause these
long-term potentially could cause
long-term brain and he may be right
right but for the for not for this
reason
it turns out more data has shown the
reason people lose their sense of smell
is that
there are these support cells around the
olfactory nerve in the nasal passages
called sustentacular cells they're like
the little um caddies for the golf cart
you know thing that that are the the
main nerve and they provide support to
the nerve cells they're the ones that
are killed off by coronavirus and that's
why they regenerate over time and then
provide support again and for some
people actually smell loss might be
permanent but it's not necessarily an
invasion into the brain that's happening
that doesn't mean that can't happen but
that's not a good reason to point at
that i think
there's there's a relief we can't blame
our stupidity on the covet
it's been an absolute pleasure i've
really enjoyed speaking with you it's
great to to get that sort of old middle
voice uh on the channel and i really
like what you are doing that doesn't
mean that you're right about everything
in the way that no one is right about
everything but i just i really
appreciate the approach and i think
this thing in particular setting aside
the medical stuff of
trying to fight
the tribalism that is just so incredibly
hard to avoid in the modern world we we
try to do that we've always tried to is
bloody difficult uh it's difficult for
all sorts of reasons uh but we really
try and i see that you're trying to do
the same and i really admire and
appreciate that so with that
go for it
i i love it i love everything you guys
are doing you you are the most
alt-middle thing i've seen on the
interwebs david fuller rebel wisdom very
similar you guys are just wonderful so
thanks so much for the
honor and pleasure of getting to talk
with you guys it's been great so we've
got a few questions for our locals which
you're on as well uh but before we do
that we've got uh so we'll do that
separately after the interview but
before we ask those questions from our
audience uh the last question we always
ask on the show is what is the one thing
that we're not talking about that we
really shouldn't be
we need to really talk about the fact
that uh social media is a new invention
that has
created the ability to create these hive
minds in a way that's so robust we have
no idea what's even happening so we are
instantiating these collective
consciousnesses that control us
we control them to a small degree but
not as much as they control us because
it's the masses instantiating this
through like share comment and it's
pushing back down on us until we
recognize this is happening and all i'll
say is this i went on a six-day silent
meditation retreat unplugged from my
phone entirely i was an entirely
different human being when i came back
and i think a lot of that was meditation
but a lot of that was not being on a
device off twitter off social media all
that and i i really encourage people to
try that and to then have the insight
that i had which was oh my god we're
being played by these massive
hyper-conscious algorithms
obviously not youtube we really like
youtube
keep promoting our stuff
absolutely that recommended speed that's
not a neuronal network at all yeah just
keep recommending our stuff please susan
don't ban bannis yeah all right uh zubin
it's been genuinely an absolute pleasure
where can people find you online tell
everybody where to go uh to check out
your work
so you just search z d o g g m d uh two
g's because one is necessary but not
sufficient to be a gangster on any
platform so youtube facebook i have
zdoggmd.com and then if you want to join
our tribe on locals we're there as well
it's an alt middle tribe really
wonderful
and you can join any of our supporter
tribe zdogmd.com forward slash
supporters
it's been a pleasure thank you very much
thank you guys
and thank you very much for watching
guys if you've enjoyed this episode uh
remember they always go out on uh
wednesday and sunday 7 p.m uk they go
out at that time no matter whether you
enjoyed this episode yeah
2 p.m eastern standard our raw shows are
at the same time but on thursday friday
and saturday and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys